Hi everyone again,
is this Shilpa we're excited to bring to you the cast and crew here from Miss
India America.
So let's give them a round of [inaudible]
plus philosophy.
I'm suspending beside me.
We have Ravi [inaudible],
the director and the writer of Miss India America alongside Mira,
who also,
um,
was played Gita in the,
in the film and is also one of the writers for the film.
Tiaa the leading actress who plays the lead Prisaad Kosha who please sima,
Lily's best friend and the in the film we have mega and Sora who are the
producers of the film.
So let's give him a round of applause.
Yeah.
Just
so we all watched the film today.
I've watched it personally about three times and I absolutely love it.
Um,
can you tell us a little bit about the inspiration behind the film and,
and what you wanted to portray in it?
It was,
uh,
you know,
Mira had a solo show called Miss Indian America,
which mega produced,
um,
that was more of a,
it was,
uh,
it was based on your life [inaudible] lane and the,
but one of the worlds that mirror had experienced was the beauty pageant world.
Cause Mirror was a former Miss India,
California,
right?
The Indian beauty pageant that I lost the Miss India USA and it was very
traumatic.
And so we had to write a movie about credit move so I could recover.
Ah,
not really.
Well we really wanted to explore the theme of winning and ambition then
particularly in the South Asian community as well.
And we thought a beauty pageant would be a perfect place to,
to,
to explore those themes.
And you know,
we were talking about this earlier,
um,
before the film started.
What a great timing to release this film.
Um,
Miss America,
as you know,
was I'm of Indian descent in 2014.
I'm just the Oscars that just came up.
Everyone was talking about diversity and the nominations.
Um,
how do you feel that this film is helping spread that awareness of diversity?
What's really great is that,
um,
it's a predominantly female south Asian American cast.
You know,
we have also,
you know,
the guys who play some really fun roles in the film.
So we,
we just,
you know,
it was time,
it was timely in the sense that,
you know,
there was a story to tell.
There are a lot of stories to tell about different worlds that are here in,
in our society.
So this was one of them.
And you know,
it was great to have this team and you know,
to be able to go into a South Asian American,
you know,
world and let that be sort of the backdrop,
right?
To explore more universal theme.
I mean,
I,
I still get excited when I see the film festival was a nice,
see all these brown women.
It's so unusual to you.
Okay.
Do you see your role?
Um,
so that kind of brings us to,
um,
Lily's character who tia plays,
who's this very strong,
confident individual and she has,
um,
what you call in the movie a lily plan.
Um,
tell us about that plan and,
and do you yourself in your personal life,
have a tia plan that you live by?
Um,
well,
I definitely relate to Lilly in some ways as these guys can probably attest to.
Maybe not when I'm around.
Um,
I have a bit of a type a personality and so in that respect I have,
I share sort of that straw,
you know,
like that drive to be that drive to excel and um,
to try and achieve perfection and like things I try my hand at,
which incidentally is why I don't play sports because I'm really bad at them.
Then I like to be good at things.
So yeah,
I guess I have a little bit in common with Lilly.
I'd like to think that I'm a little more well rounded than lily and maybe I have
better interpersonal skills,
I hope.
Um,
but yeah,
so I mean,
I,
yeah,
I think I'm have always been pretty driven and maybe a little ambitious and so,
uh,
maybe I have,
have had a tia plan,
but I never made a scrapbook.
Maybe I wasn't so organized in,
in enough to do something like that.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I guess I do have a lot in common with Willie for better or for worse.
Um,
so Kosha,
your character,
um,
Sema is,
Lee's best friend in the film.
You kind of take this selflessness role,
which is quite opposite from Lily's role.
Um,
how,
what was,
you know,
how did you feel playing that emotionally,
that character and,
and do you as a person resonate with that personality?
Um,
I definitely resonated with that personally.
I don't know.
I feel like it came very natural to me.
I've always been someone who has a lot of female friendships in my life.
I went to an all girls school,
so I knew what it's like to sort of put others first and then do the opposite
and put myself first.
I think those fine lines of friendship are really interesting and exciting to
me.
And,
um,
yeah.
So
That's interesting.
So I guess in terms of that challenge,
in playing that role,
what was the most difficult pieces of playing sema?
You know what?
I feel like this is maybe the first time I've ever been able to say this,
but this role actually wasn't super challenging for me because it was very cool.
Sorry,
it's very close to myself and that was such a privilege for me because usually I
think you can attest to this.
I don't get to play characters that are similar to myself.
So when I read this script and approach this character,
I just embraced every part of me personally that I haven't been able to play in
other characters as producer is having,
you know,
a large cast to work with.
What was your challenge in terms of making sure that everything was on schedule
and on time?
In terms of filming?
We were always on schedule.
Think for the most part,
we were always on schedule,
fortunately,
uh,
because this was an independent film through and through,
the cast and the crew were game.
Uh,
they,
they knew that this was the link to be a labor of love for,
uh,
for almost all parties involved.
And because of that,
uh,
there are all kinds of things that you have to eat.
Everyone kind of has to wear many different hats.
But fortunately if your buddy was was up for that and that,
uh,
that kept us,
kept us going and kept us on time and kept us on schedule.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of comradery,
you know,
with the,
with the cast,
with the crew,
with we had seen,
so we had hundreds of extras and I think it created a very familial type of
atmosphere and I think everyone got along quite nicely.
And we've been together now for,
I mean Mirror Ravi and absorb and I for years,
but with the cast over three years,
so we've continued to move with the film,
which is nice.
Mickey,
it was also super,
super organized.
Uh,
so that should've been my short answer.
That's the reason why
they were married.
By the way.
Can you tell two married couples here?
That's Marin rubber.
Yeah.
Until you [inaudible] catching up.
We live in the same house now.
We don't,
it was interesting with the scheduling and keeping things on track,
I hadn't realized really thought about how long it would take to the heroin
Mecca for that many women.
And some of the biggest thing in this as well.
So it was always like,
so when do we get the actors on set?
It's like another two hours
and rightly so.
But yeah,
just they have to look at,
I know if we had a few more minutes they to,
they had to look missing him.
Eric.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean
specifically it's a lovely dress up.
It was a lot of,
sorry,
it's a lot of uh,
Indian [inaudible] cost 14.
Yeah,
I had to put you in twice.
I liked it.
I thought,
I love that stuff.
This whole like Indian dance costume,
which has like all this like head jewelry.
I mean,
some of you probably know it and bangles and they're like six different pieces
of clothing has to be attached to a particular way and it's all danced.
So.
Yes.
Yeah.
So,
and then he did it.
Um,
and speaking about some of the traditional wardrobe and pieces,
I think that the story took a very interesting perspective because there's a lot
of progressive scenes.
You had the traditional bark,
not the dancer who's rang the traditional garb they described,
um,
dating and a non ethnic character.
And then you had,
um,
keep us character who played,
who was played by Mira m who was this mom,
but she wasn't the traditional mom that you saw cooking in any scene.
She was the mom that was a poet and successful.
Um,
so what,
you know,
what inspired you or what kind of triggered
some of those scenes and where they based on a true story?
It
in terms of the dancing,
um,
I studied Indian classical dance birth,
not Tim,
along with Mega.
Um,
and
okay.
What inspired I think those scenes,
and I'm rubbing,
I wrote this together.
So it's kind of these two voices coming together and that,
you know,
I,
I never,
I was into my dancing but not really.
And I think I just kind of strayed away from it and had this whole other life in
a different way.
I wanted to express myself and Robbie,
you know,
would write these plays to that.
You know,
he wrote a play based on the Ramayana.
So that scene was kind of bringing our lives together to sort of,
you know,
kind of,
um,
really delve into this well,
why is,
you know,
this character seat,
that sitting there and it is something lily would say,
you know,
and it is something we've talked about and explored and,
and it ups if the father and the mother and the mother being a poet and the
father being a brain surgeon,
everything when we were writing the script was about,
well it was about the character of lily.
So how did those,
how do these other characters reflect on her and how the date define that
character of Lilly.
And so with a mother who was like,
so let's create this character,
which she really butts up against if the opposite of Lilly as a poet in some
ways because she is so heavy.
Yeah.
Where was the mother was more heart driven and emotional.
And then the father of course was with somebody that she looked up to and,
and related to.
So all the other characters kind of came,
came in and relief to the character of Lilly.
And,
um,
there was a very interesting,
and dynamic that Lily's character had because in the movie when you first
started,
um,
you wanted to kind of,
you didn't relate to this character.
Do you want it to almost not cheer for her and then Theresa puncher in and,
Oh yeah,
you did.
I'm sorry,
my job here was done.
Um,
but then towards the end,
you started to cheer for this character and you wanted to love her and you
wanted her to win,
um,
and being number one.
Um,
and so,
you know,
how did that feel for you guys in that journey of really building her character
and lily or Tia,
playing that character?
Like,
well,
how did you feel?
What were the challenges you felt to kind of express those,
that sentiment?
Well,
I,
um,
I felt,
even though I wasn't lily exactly growing up,
I'm sure my parents would have loved me to be a little more like lily as far as
school was concerned.
Um,
but even though I wasn't her,
I felt like from the moment I first read this script,
um,
not only did I think the script was just so well written and so funny,
but also something I connected immediately with this character.
And even though I wasn't her,
I felt like I knew her intimately well.
And I sort of recognize parts of me and her.
Um,
I have an older sister who is like typical first born child model,
student model kid.
Um,
so I,
I recognize parts of my sister and her,
so I just,
I felt like I knew this person really,
really well and um,
felt like I,
I really had to portray her if I read it sort of in a very early stage before it
was actually getting made into a movie.
And I,
at that point I was like,
if this thing ever gets made into a movie,
I'm going to fight tooth and nail to get this job.
Luckily they didn't make me do that again,
but,
um,
oh,
sorry.
I digress.
But I,
I,
um,
I just felt like I knew her and I had to play her and I felt,
I almost saw her as a sympathetic character.
And so none of those things even occurred to me for some reason until after the
fact.
And I know I've told him,
said this story before,
but,
um,
I think maybe at our wrap party or some right after we wrapped production,
one of the pas who had read the script early on said,
well,
I never told you this until now,
but I read the script and I really hated the Labor side.
And I was really nervous that we were going to make a movie where the
protagonist is like this super unlikable character and now that we're done,
I'm really glad that I,
I don't,
I don't hate her.
Like I,
I like her at the end,
which is,
I mean,
yeah,
hopefully that's the case.
Um,
but it was sort of a luxury.
That was the first time it ever occurred to me that someone would look at her
and dislike her.
I just felt like I understood her strengths and her weaknesses.
And so I had this sort of luxury of not realizing that until after we were done.
I just sort of played,
played her as truthfully as I could and whatever happened happened I guess.
Oh,
well done.
I don't think so.
I really,
I wanted to hug you and I felt bad that you won third place.
I think at the end it was a second or third place.
Uh,
I,
yeah,
you were a second third and play those.
Okay.
Yeah.
Lawrence not to win all the time and it wasn't good was okay.
Um,
and so I guess like talking about before we open it up to the audience,
let's talk about the cast a little bit.
I know that,
um,
we don't have Hannah Simone who stars in the new girl here today who also plays,
I'm Sonia Nelson,
one of the contestants for Miss India America.
Um,
and you have to leading,
um,
females here.
How was the casting process for you guys?
Um,
and was it difficult to find,
um,
Indian American actors for the film?
You know,
so it took it about the Lita Lee character of lily.
We knew we needed to find somebody that could take the audience on a journey on
this supposedly on,
on,
on sympathetic character that did appear on sympathetic on the page,
but would still make us invested in her journey.
And we kept saying,
we need to find our Indian Reese Witherspoon.
And uh,
I think kind of got it.
I think,
uh,
you know,
two did an amazing job on his own.
He knows,
we like to say,
you know,
Reese Witherspoon is the white a ts her car.
That's what everyone's saying on the street,
right?
Yeah.
And it's like,
wait,
so knew a lot of the actors,
like Tiaa Mirror had played her mom twice before on TV show was.
And I actually played her dad on one of those shows too.
So we knew Tiaa,
we already like,
yeah,
she can be brilliant.
And then like kosher,
I saw on a short film,
I was like,
I'm like a kosher went through the reading.
And so there were a lot of people who we knew and there was some people who we
didn't know and we were surprised by the depth of talent and the South Asian
community.
Now it's pretty phenomenal.
Yeah.
Think it was great to have,
you know,
just a wealth of talent come in and audition and,
and to see that they're just really good,
you know?
Really good.
And you know,
you've said this a lot too,
where like,
you know,
maybe five,
10 years ago there weren't as many,
you know,
it might've been hard to cast this film
might've been hard.
Do you think it would have been the same if it was,
had a more of a,
a male predominant character kind of platform?
Or are you think it would just have been it just the same wealth and depth of
talent out there would be the same for a male versus a female?
I think it's pretty,
I mean,
what do you guys think?
I think it's pretty,
you know,
even and things,
so they went from a very female heavy movie to the next film I made,
which is very male heavy.
And again,
South Asian,
um,
there's a lot of talent.
I mean we're still lucky that we get to try out eight to 10,
sometimes 12 people for a role,
which is really exciting.
Um,
so we're going to open the floor up to questions.
if you guys feel could go up to the mic and,
and please ask a question to the talent.
Hi.
Uh,
I wanted to thank you guys for making a movie that was,
you know,
you don't,
a lot of times when you see Indians are represented on screen,
it's Indian,
Indian or immigrant Indians.
And like the story of those of us who grew up here,
it doesn't really get told.
But on top of that,
I liked it.
It was a very specific story.
Like it wasn't about trying to get everything about him being an Indian American
out there.
And I wonder it like,
can I talk to a few writers and various other communities?
Like,
did you,
did you choose writers feel kind of like,
you have to fight that urge to be like,
well,
I have to get every,
get everything about being an Indian American down on this page right now
because otherwise this will be the one movie where that,
no,
I,
I don't,
we didn't have to,
uh,
fight that urge to talk about,
you know,
being an Indian American,
we,
um,
we knew that this sort of story that we wanted to tell him what we wanted to
explore and if anything it was just using,
we happened to be Indian American.
It happens,
you know,
the beauty pageant world is a backdrop orange county,
but the world that we live in,
you know,
it was very,
human and connected in that way.
And I think those themes of being an Indian American and have been explored in
films earlier on like um,
American day C and a,
B,
c,
d and You know,
they,
they've explored those themes and maybe as a,
as a group now our voices to um,
our stories are different,
you know,
and what we want to talk about is different.
Thank you.
Okay,
thanks for sharing that.
Anybody else from the audience?
Oh we have the distributor.
Just an innocent person.
So you guys were talking about,
uh,
you both had the background in the traditional dances but you both had to,
as actresses portray a certain expertise on screen,
especially you Cosha who had to say,
I've been doing this,
I know this and now I have to coach someone who doesn't know how much had you
guys worked on that before or had it in your lives before you even got to the
movie.
I actually am maybe the only one here that didn't have a dance background,
which was like excellent.
Cause my character is not supposed to be amazing at it.
So that goes back to what I was saying earlier.
I got to like really embrace everything about myself.
Um,
so I learned the choreography,
which was exciting to me cause I don't have a dance background and I didn't have
to make it look perfect the way someone would like lily would move.
Very cool.
I thought every Indian girl just knew how to dance
and dance.
But yeah,
I know I haven't like bust a move the traditional time,
not the traditional type.
I'm with you on that.
I relate.
I could do a little bunker up.
Yeah.
Punjab EMC taught me that.
[inaudible] Punjabi.
No,
I'm good.
Dropping.
Oh,
I was going to say,
I mean Punjabi is just,
it's like in your DNA you have to know how to be [inaudible].
My question has already been answered a little bit because I was initially
wondering about the existence of Miss India and the idea of cultural beauty
pageants within the u s and so I'd like to expand it.
I,
so you were Miss India or California,
Diego,
California years ago,
and I'm sort of intrigued what the,
what the weight of that in,
in relation to the traditional culture and the American culture and how that
played out for you?
I'm,
I'm just intrigued.
Can you tell me more?
Right.
Um,
yes,
I would
[inaudible] that's
the word.
Um,
you know,
I think,
I don't know what it's like when I,
when I did it,
um,
there was a group of girls who would go and we'd do these beauty pageants.
Um,
it was,
uh,
for different reasons.
I think it was a cultural thing.
I think,
you know,
when we were younger,
we want it to be seen.
Um,
that was there,
you know,
and,
um,
maybe we wanted a crown and,
you know,
get our face in the paper.
And it was that kind of thing.
And,
um,
there were very,
uh,
and it was also like,
I think,
uh,
a dance,
you know,
a place where you can showcase the talent too.
So it was all these different things.
And I think,
you know,
for me,
looking back on it,
it was,
um,
it was just one of those things I did that I would go,
okay,
that was part of my experience of growing up and I was able to,
you know,
bring it into this,
story that we told them.
It's interesting now when you look at the girls that do the beauty pageants now,
they're,
they're really accomplished there.
This is just one aspect of their lives.
They're going to beat doctors,
they're going to be lawyers,
they're going to be nurses,
they're going to be engineers,
but they also have this,
this pull towards doing these pageants as well when I think it's a little bit to
do with the Bollywood thing to that,
because Bollywood at the payment is still still kind of gets into their homes
and into their lives.
They want to kind of touch that a little bit as well.
And there's a value to that too.
Yeah.
And I think it's also the expectation of,
of,
uh,
Indian women in this country as well,
to be everything as well.
They have to be,
they're expected to be intelligent and smart and they're expected to be
entertained as and,
and,
uh,
and to show off their talents,
to
no confidence,
confident us,
play at least one.
Amen.
And Sing and dance and dance and go to Stanford,
ugly.
At the same time they'll go to Stanford and get your,
um,
electrical engineering degree know,
I think that was also a big part of it too.
Yeah.
And in some ways,
even the title Miss India America,
it's,
it's a,
it's a wider idea of if the title of what does it mean to be Miss India America?
What's,
what is the expectation that that's put on by other people in on themselves too.
That's actually interesting because that was a question that was submitted was,
you know,
in today's Miss India America,
what should she look like?
What,
how would you describe her today?
Right,
yeah,
yeah.
Of what I think,
you know,
for her,
for any kind of culturally specific,
a beauty pageant or,
or,
or similar kinds of events.
Um,
you know,
whenever you have,
particularly if we're getting communities,
uh,
in the u s ideas of standards of beauty,
those are,
uh,
ideas that sometimes get challenged a little bit.
And I think what these events,
uh,
for all that we can make fun of them for,
which I think,
you know,
there our film does,
uh,
there also is though a real sense of celebration,
you know,
celebration of,
of this particular culture and this particular look and,
and,
uh,
putting value,
in that and within the context of American society as well.
And I don't think there's one look that there isn't one ideal.
You know,
I mean,
if we're looking in the broader sense,
our title of Miss Indian America isn't,
uh,
isn't just a beauty pageant,
you know,
title it's,
somatically,
much broader.
And,
you know,
it's so interesting to see are,
young girls,
you know,
growing up and you want them to be able to feel comfortable in their bodies and
whatever they have and whatever they want to do.
So I just don't think there's one definition of what that Miss India America is.
It's just,
it's who you are,
you know,
and,
and do you even,
you know,
yeah,
no.
Yeah,
I totally,
um,
as a person,
as an individual,
I totally relate.
I relate to that.
And I think that you drew it into the film pretty well.
When,
um,
Sima who's played by Kosha,
uh,
was told by the judge that she should not be in the pageant because she wasn't
contestant Mike or she wasn't as tall as,
you know,
the character who's played by Tiaa.
Um,
how did that make you make you feel in,
in that moment when you were told maybe you weren't fair and lovely,
like we're,
we're brought up to believe,
um,
and that you couldn't be part of it.
Not Great.
[inaudible]
I,
I think it's a,
I think it brought up like a very interesting and important point about what all
young Indian girls go through.
And,
um,
I also think it was interesting because I don't know if you feel like this is an
actor,
but in Hollywood everyone has this idea.
Like these Indian characters are written and everyone has this idea as to what
they are.
But none of us fit into that square box.
So,
uh,
I think it mirrored something that we all experience and it was really great to
explore that in the film and not have to fit into that box that sometimes when
we're doing other jobs,
we have to.
Yeah.
That's really a great way to,
um,
I know I always wished that I was five,
seven,
so I could be part of it,
you know,
that's never going to happen in my life.
Did you do it all right?
Yeah.
Um,
so any questions on the floor?
Do we have any?
Okay.
Oh boy.
Um,
this is for the actors.
Do you feel like in the last few years,
like in the wake of Oscars so white and all of this stuff in terms of diversity
in Hollywood,
do you feel like the roles have changed for you guys?
Do you feel like they're more opportunities out there and different roles and
better roles?
I would say absolute.
Thank you for your question.
Um,
I would say,
I mean,
you guys are,
there's a bunch of actors up here.
Um,
even in the short amount of time I've been acting professionally in Hollywood,
I have seen a marked change in the kinds of roles,
uh,
that,
that networks and studios will even consider South Asian actors for.
And,
um,
I mean,
I still,
I definitely think we have a long way to go and,
uh,
but I s t I s I see a tangible change and,
and,
and difference.
And from,
from when I first started working in this industry,
um,
you know,
uh,
a role on a television show might say,
you know,
the casting notice might say like ethnically ambiguous or are open to all
ethnicities,
but really they would mean probably African American.
And then maybe if they're feeling a little,
you know,
gutsy,
they'll go Latina and then if they're really trying to like push the push the
limits,
they'll go Asian American.
But South Asian American was still so,
so,
um,
so crazy of an idea that it was hard.
I think,
I mean,
I was up for,
you guys probably had the same experience.
I was up for roles where I would be testing for a pilot and the network,
say we love Tia and she was really great,
but we're going to choose this Latina.
I mean this happened once in particular,
we're going to pick this Latina actress because this particular network,
40% of their viewership was Latina.
And I was like,
oh,
but maybe just pick the person that was the best at the job.
So,
you know,
I've had countless experiences like that one.
And now I feel like only in the last couple of years there've been such changes
in like who we see in mainstream media.
And um,
it,
you know,
with your Mindi Kailyn's and your Aziz Ansari's and um,
Priyanka Chopra is even,
you know,
um,
it's,
it's exciting.
I feel like we're right on the brink of really,
uh,
becoming so,
um,
so,
so integrated in mainstream media that hopefully soon we won't even need to like
comment about it.
I mean,
I know that might be a little ways off,
but I see changes happening and it's very exciting and miss Indian America is
going to be the reason.
Hope so.
We're ready.
Thank you.
Um,
so as writers and kind of understanding that the,
the challenge that actors have and in getting some of these type of roles,
do you feel added pressure to write scripts that are catered towards a more
diverse or niche community?
I mean,
I think we just want to tell stories which do touch on the South Asian American
experience.
I think we're passionate about doing those stories.
You know,
it's not an easy road as well.
It's a cause where it's still trying to,
we're trying to figure out his or a marketplace for them as well.
And how,
how,
um,
how much do we need to win to gray,
the white American experience within those stories of the South Asian American
experience.
We're still discovering it.
But I know from my perspective,
I want to keep telling the stories about these brown people,
you know,
because we talk a lot about if we don't write the stories and nobody else is
going to do them,
and that won't be a narrative,
a historical narrative in some ways that you can point to and go,
so what was it like to be a South Asian American in 2050 or whatever?
And you go,
oh well is this movie and this movie in that movie,
go check them out and you'll get a sense of it.
And if we don't do them,
then they just won't be there.
Yeah.
And there's,
you know,
there's a lot of really interesting filmmakers who are telling these stories.
And as a writer,
I think it's not challenging to write a fully formed,
you know,
three dimensional person who is like,
happens to be South Asian.
So it's really great that there's a complexity too.
And there's something,
there's a depth and there's a history and the way they relate to each other too
and just women relating to each other.
We relate to each other.
In so many different ways.
And,
and I think,
you know,
we both won.
We weren't like,
we didn't have an agenda.
I don't think in writing this,
it was more just let's tell this story.
And,
and through telling this story,
these,
these things happen.
Do you know where women are talking about their friendships or they're about,
you know,
this idea of being driven and how far they're going to go and their
relationships.
And then there's love.
Yeah.
And there,
you know,
so a lot of different things.
And so that's really exciting.
I think that just as a speaking as a producer,
you know,
even when I was just reading the script,
the Mira and Ravi wrote,
um,
there was a universality to,
uh,
the,
the situations to the struggles that the characters are going through.
And I think that a good way of maybe looking at it is just,
it's having a real respect for,
uh,
an audience.
Any kind of audience doesn't even have to be a specifically South Asian,
but it's just telling really,
really good stories.
And it happens to be this particular South Asian experience.
But within that,
you know,
supposedly narrow experience,
you can find the universe,
you know,
within that.
That's interesting.
Um,
so we're,
I guess we could just go down online,
so what's next for each one of you guys?
Get something that you're working on the next,
you know,
in the near future or where can we see you next?
[inaudible]
uh,
so,
from my self a,
so a meg and I are developing,
you know,
a handful of projects,
um,
uh,
sure.
Uh,
how,
how much we can really say.
Well,
there's one,
it's,
it's a children's entertainment brand called super duper princess heroes.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
a,
it's,
it's geared towards a young,
very young audience,
but tries to teach values of female empowerment,
uh,
in a very fun,
sort of,
uh,
Popey a superhero slash princessy atmosphere.
Um,
and,
uh,
yeah,
we have a couple of her film projects that we're developing as well and yeah,
you can talk about your,
your next one.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I shot right after Miss Indian America shot the tiger hunter,
so that's coming out in the next few weeks.
It's starting at the festival circuit and,
um,
and then the super duper princess heroes.
And I am continuing to try and create as much comedy as I can and I'm working on
a show that will be on MTV.
I would love to tell you the title,
but it keeps switching to untitled,
but it's about weed dealers.
Um,
I,
uh,
just uh,
wrap production on a pilot for NBC,
um,
that Amy Poehler,
executive produced and directed,
which is really exciting.
Um,
and then I've voiced a character on a couple of different animated shows.
One is star wars rebels,
which,
um,
our season two finale event is tomorrow night and airs on Disney XD.
And then,
um,
I just started working on another one.
It's a project for a drip for dreamworks,
for Netflix,
Netflix.
Why can't I talk and I can't talk about it?
Yeah.
Specifically because I've been told not to,
but I hopefully will get to soon.
Um,
Robbie and I,
uh,
I have written a half hour,
a single camera comedy,
uh,
called in transit about,
um,
it's set in the 70s,
and it's based on my childhood
growing up in San Diego.
Oh Wow.
So
a lot of inspiration from within your own childhood that yeah.
That is portrayed in your writing.
That's great.
And I just stopped like a vampire and yes,
take a story is it
creates,
yeah.
Um,
and so just before we go into this rapid fire round,
we've prepared for you guys.
It'll be really quick.
Um,
it's not scary.
You'll,
you'll eat.
Yeah.
Um,
so when,
um,
the folks that didn't get to watch the film today,
where can they see it?
Um,
and where can they find it?
So we're pretty much on every major digital streaming platforms starting April
5th,
uh,
including Google play.
Uh,
but,
uh,
just if you just look for Miss Indian America,
you're almost guaranteed to find it on any of your on demand or streaming
channels.
Yeah.
And for those of you in mountain view?
Uh,
I,
as I said before,
we're still playing in San Jose,
so definitely tell your bay area friends to check us out.
All right.
Um,
so we're going to do really quickly,
it was going to take a few minutes and we're going to do a rapid fire round.
I'm going to ask you a question.
We'll just go down the line and just say the first thing that comes to mind
when,
when I say this.
Um,
and uh,
okay.
Ravi is saying we start with you Sarah.
All right.
Um,
okay.
So your favorite search engine,
Google or bing?
Google.
Google,
Why do people use thing?
I heard they pay you to use it.
Oh guys and Google for sure.
Google.
I Google it.
I've never even dumping.
Oh No.
Awesome.
We,
we paid them all to say that.
Okay.
Um,
so if you had to pick your favorite movie between these two,
which one would be the internship or the intern?
The internships.
I said I'm going to have to say the internship.
The intern.
Thanks guys.
The internship,
the internship.
And I haven't seen the and so the internship as well by default.
Yes,
I'd okay
being either,
so I,
all my answers are going to be by default
internship is pageant Miss Universe or Miss Rod.
Ooh,
Miss World Underground.
I actually do like Miss World Better
Miss Universe.
Which one doesn't have the swimsuit competition?
That one.
Just one of them know how to I think so.
This is a one word answer.
Sorry.
I knew I was gonna be terrible at this.
Do we know?
Are we sure?
Now we know who miss universes.
Oh,
right,
right.
Um,
Gosh.
Miss World.
Miss Universe,
miss anything.
Miss any miss everything.
Donald Trump does the Miss Universe,
right?
Okay.
Does that,
that affect your decision?
Did you know miss everything?
Paul Mrs. Cooper.
I'll go pull with that.
Okay.
Miss India.
America.
Yeah.
That was off the charts.
But I like it.
You're a writer so you can write in what you want to say.
Facebook or snapchat?
Facebook.
I'm too old for snapchat.
Facebook,
Facebook.
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm getting into snapchat.
She saw a youngster.
I'll go,
fuck,
I'm going to have to go Facebook.
But I did my first snapchat on a red carpet last night and it was thrilling and
terrifying at the same time.
So maybe snapchat soon.
Oh,
that sounds exciting.
Yes.
Facebook,
I don't even know.
What is it the same?
I can barely cope with any of them kind of nick.
And by default I've never done snapchat.
So Facebook.
Okay,
so he's going to ask you guys Facebook or Instagram,
but it's Instagram,
Instagram,
obvious one.
Okay.
Who is the Facebook thing?
It's good.
Good to know.
Bollywood or Hollywood?
Yep.
Oh Man.
Uh,
Hollywood.
I gotta I gotta I gotta get a Hollywood or Bollywood,
but,
but I will say I'm a South Asian American independent film over both.
Oh,
I think I would go for like seventies Bollywood and,
and then,
yeah,
independent to errors then that's different.
I'm going to go with Hollywood as am I.
Hollywood,
Hollywood Bollywood Crossover.
You're answers are not answer.
Okay.
Hollywood.
I'm not committing.
Am I knocking middle?
It's all gray.
And I've never seen a Bollywood movie.
So now Emma,
Holly rusted millions of Bollywood Kapore and sons steer that the other day.
Good things about it.
That it was good in science.
It wasn't about me then when I was just saying it should be about you.
Yeah,
I was like what?
But it's still here.
Am I in this film?
Where am I in this bill?
What am my sons?
So the next thing,
and please say one word.
Okay.
So if you were going to be great,
I asked you a question as a,
as a pageant contestant,
what would you incorporate in your answer at child poverty or world peace.
World peace.
Tell it poverty.
Oh,
Sema Kosha.
Child poverty.
World peace.
World.
Peace.
World peace.
Oh Nice.
Um,
we saw a lot of child poverty in the movies.
Then surprise.
Maybe you'll have tried [inaudible] I was thinking is,
is that okay?
I was thinking,
okay,
we all thought like if you have world peace then these two to
maybe you might have world peace,
hungry chicken
could be all about this.
Um,
so final four team,
who do you want to win for March madness?
They're not in it anymore,
but UCLA.
So the choices are Villanova,
Oklahoma,
North Carolina,
or Syracuse,
Villanova.
I'm to say North Carolina Pass.
I know nothing about basketball.
It's a basketball [inaudible] path.
Um,
this is not a very nice answer,
but I'm from Texas,
so anybody but Oklahoma.
Okay.
We'll take that.
I'm going to say Syracuse because I know people from Syracuse,
but I know nothing about big basketball fans on [inaudible].
America's going to be playing basketball,
basketball.
I was like,
we're really living up [inaudible] basketball thing.
I love to see that.
Tia Kosha.
Can you put something like that together?
For sure.
I can handle the garden.
Not The end part.
Not the basket robot because the,
the orange uniforms
I picked good ones.
Team writers.
Um,
so the last question for you guys,
are you in it to win it?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
All Day,
baby.
Why not?
Yes.
I guess I committed.
I'm going to to be in it.
I'm definitely in it for when it.
Thank you guys so much for joining us here today.
I can Google [inaudible].
Thank you all.